[Applause]
[Music]
one of the best games of his life
gets the roll count it in one the only
one that has anything going at the
offensive end
great strength to get that shot up
and in after taking a pretty hard hit
hooker on the drive gets inside triple t
finds cam johnson
shot clock winding down bunker blocked
by antenna wide open dunk down the other
end
giannis has been great
and i think middleton's really improved
there and again they're going to play
without a point guard this half
tucker the runner oh god the big on the
floor comes over and tries to block the
layup at temple pj tucker
nobody puts a body on giannis and he
punishes the smaller
phoenix suns guys rotating
holiday back on booker the pentagon will
pick them up
hookah's blocked by attack because he
didn't get this call they're asking
where's the technical foul
similar to the one that porter's got
[Music]
almighty williams says mikhail bridges
running the floor shot blocked by
antenna
once again comes out of nowhere and
throws it off the backboard
you understand the other ending just a
tremendous
in-transition chase down play
great run by bridges
[Applause]
on the offensive end catch finish
[Applause]
this is reminiscent of lebron james
in cleveland against golden state what
an effort
incredible block
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he soars and scores active denial
comes up with the deflection easy
opportunity in transition off of the
stellar defense
one thing i would do if i was a bucks
right now coach i'd trap chris paul in
the pick-and-roll action
[Music]
[ __ ] the drive gets inside leans in
knocked away and stolen by holiday
phoenix has to foul throws it down
made the right three throws it up where
only giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact what up
it's your boy adam lefkow did you like
that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report